il a été arrêté jeudi dernier en
belgique
michel fourniret est un forestier
français de 61 ans présenté comme un bon
père de famille
toute la journée sa maison a été
fouillée par la police pour vérifier
s'il n'y avait pas de cash dans son
voisinage
cette nouvelle a provoqué des réactions
mitigées s'il a jamais eu un geste
déplacé envers moi je n'ai rien du tout
ni dromard cyprien ya eu beaucoup
d'ennuis avec tout le monde
il en veut à tout le monde michel
fourniret a été incarcéré après avoir
tant que dans le v10 est une jeune fille
de 13
dans ces ruelles de signer une localité
proche de la frontière française
il lui a d'abord demandé son chemin
avant de la kidnapper de la ligoter
par chance cette jeune victime a réussi
à s'enfuir en sautant du fourgon en
marche une tentative de rapt qui a eu
lieu à quelques kilomètres seulement de
charleville mézières où céline 18 ans
avait disparu en mai 2000 un an plus
tard près de sedan magnagna une jeune
fille de 13 ans était enlevé à son tour
de disparition qui s'était produite
également plein jour
les corps des deux victimes avait été
retrouvé dans les bois en belgique des
similitudes troublantes pour les
enquêteurs français et belge n'est pas
de certitudes pour faire un lien entre
ces trois affaires nous sommes au tout
début d'une enquête
nous allons investiguer une fermerons
aucune piste mais pour le moment je
ferai pas familial michel fourniret
était déjà connu des services de police
français pour des délits à connotation
sexuelle
des vérifications sont en cours mais les
enquêteurs restent prudents pour ne pas
donner de faux espoirs aux familles des
deux jeunes filles assassinées